previously on TV sentence and probably
watching me well let them let them see
what kind of a person I am I'm not even
gonna SWAT that fly I hope they are
watching there see they'll see and they
don't know and they'll say why she
wouldn't even harm a fly
if you can get your hands on a tanker
your people our person wants to know
you've already name drop negan's your
property now belongs to negan so why are
we still playing the pronoun game if you
have to eat that's not the nibble bite
chew swallow repeat it goes quicker show
steals my mantra when I realize I have
to send yet another episode of The
Walking Dead and I just don't want to
also doesn't it actually go quicker if
you don't chew and just swallow and if
you have the spit option why would you
ever chew or swallow it Oh show doesn't
know how to blow job I mean each right
we introduce ourselves by just popping
one of you right off the bat hey bat
shadowing is our thing damnit I'm not
gonna kill you you know what you say
they use explosion occur is this bike
Elton John because despite an explosion
that literally disintegrated humans this
bike is still standing that have super
powers coming to AMC next fall another
Walking Dead spin-off Norman Reedus
presents the standing bike he cut you a
little so squall can I somehow manage to
decommission a man with an automatic
weapon in a scuffle where he took a cut
then find loan and fire an RPG all
without being seen or heard by anyone
just a few feet away
hell I've already been plenty annoyed
how easily this zombie slime life hack
works but now the show is spending two
full minutes just rubbing my face in it
and I've had enough it's like this
entire scene exists to show that the
dead would actually be great neighbors
just throw on your shirt take a walk in
the park no worries new plan now they're
just gonna step aside and have a
conversation and this doesn't get the
attention of any of the actual walkers
what Judith doesn't get the ultimate
death gamma was target sold out of human
flesh onesies yes oh for skips sakes
cute I really haven't had an episode
that showed Eugene and all his mullet
Gloria business in the front party in
the back but sinned through and through
when I wanted to run you said that's how
you lose people even after they're gone
what the hell does that mean Enid would
be fantastic of TV since you said that
wasn't born this way show dares to
contradict Lady Gaga on that shall not
stand you keep looking for the Bible
clock you're right
technically that appears to be a cigar
box clock and not a Bible Glock but
semantics you see that one day yes you
will be given an unbelievable 2019 that
would go down in the history books if it
wasn't for Florence pew pew I think them
holding hands is supposed to be
representative of trust or something but
all I see is the world's grossest game
of Red Rover dead burger dead Rovers and
the disemboweled guy right over so wait
what did poor Sam do to get attacked
sure he whimpered but not like he was
any louder than any other talking
they've been doing is it because he was
standing still because they've all been
standing there waiting for him the same
amount of time and little due to
simultaneously attacked by three zombies
something triggered them guessing
zombies can sense when the plot momentum
is stalling it has to be done
speaking of which we are now halfway
through this episode so let's run down
what happened between the opening
explosion in these deaths two minutes of
walking amongst the dead about a minute
of hardcore planning action evil a bird
mother and son conversation about
staying together or not another minute
of random zombies another debate about
whether we should stay or go
the edge-of-your-seat morgan wakes up
seen the Glen and Enid search at church
for a gun and talk philosophy for a few
minutes montage the creepy forehead w
guy talks menacingly to Merritt Wever
for a few minutes and finally a few more
minutes of some zombie crowd control
this show is boring
well those three are gone now
bing-bam-boom it's like they're
pointless storylines never happened
Breaking Bad did it better also he
survives this meet while on Waiting for
Godot sooner or later no way yeah
knowing this show I put the heavy
favorite on the later option and
thankfully all the walkers were wearing
up of the storyline that they are
holding off attacking us just long
enough to have this conversation you had
a child right husband show makes the
mistake of bringing up storylines from
better seasons that I would much rather
be watching now okay the show is just
whipping out its inconsistency again and
waving it in our faces it tries to
pretend that surviving zombies is hard
and then has this guy literally moshpit
his way through three of them with a
light shove who needs a gun when you can
just play zombie pinball instead it
doesn't die in this scene you probably
think I meant to say Rick survives this
but I did not no one gets the clock out
today and he'll this is a story people
are gonna do yes a story of how people
finally realize Dom bees are dumb slow
and easily beatable I'm sure this
American life has their best producers
on it right now
maybe actually hitting a few of the
walkers with bullets wouldn't hurt well
now I'm confused as to how Maggie is
trapped up here when she very clearly
could have gone down the way Enid just
came up and sure she needed a zombie
distraction but why did Amy need to go
up there at all
Clint so Darrell's plan is to pollute
the entire water supply and then light
up the night sky in a way that paints a
target on their back for any walkers or
other humans nearby maybe I was wrong
maybe the zombies aren't for da ones
[Music]
just without any depth perception
because that ship has sailed son
[Music]
I'm not gonna kill you you know what you
saying what manner of man are you that
can summon up fire without Flint or
tinder hey I'm an enchanter
you're right I changed and now I'm gonna
help you change yeah
come with me if you want to live praying
that God will save our town I do it
myself